portland seeing yet another week of
violence the city's mayor condemning
rioters for trying to set fire to a
police precinct
and blocking the exits while cops were
still inside
take a look when you commit arson with
an
accelerant in an attempt to burn down a
building that is
occupied by people that you have
intentionally trapped inside
you are not demonstrating you are
attempting
to commit murder
dana you're a communications expert um
you've got
one mayor you got a mayor in seattle
liking it to
a block party and you have a mayor in
portland liking it to
attempted murder why the messaging
disparity
will this be a november issue and how do
you reconcile
advocating for an improved justice
system while separating yourself from
anarchy those are all excellent
questions all i could think of when i
was sitting there you know watching him
is i would like to respond in kind i was
like you sir
you are the one who were who allowed
this to happen for 70 days
you sir are the one that are responsible
for this
situation you are the one who has ended
up with these pictures
all over the country and now you're
upset because you're worried that it
actually might
help the republicans and the election
are you kidding me yes
when when you have small business owners
are completely unable
to do their work you have moms and dads
who think i don't know if this is going
to happen and look
i know this is happening in portland and
it looks
and i know it's not happening right here
in in the city where i'm living in right
or this little town but in your mind
when you see these images play over and
over again yeah you think
there is a very fine line between
civilization and anarchy
and the mayor of portland is the one
that basically blurred that line
so now he has to go on zoom to try to
ask
the people to back off it seems like
much too little way too late
well greg dana mentioned anarchy um
the the problem with anarchy is
eventually you're going to run into a
law that you actually think
should be enforced yeah and then it's
too late because the law has been
undercut so you know where is the line
between peaceful protest
and what we see in some of these
northwestern
northwestern cities well where is the
proper line between peaceful protest
and what we're seeing the lawlessness
anyone can see
that line it's called violence it's
called destruction of property it's
called intimidating and
abusing the elderly when an elderly
woman is trying to put out a fire
and they harass her or when another
elderly woman is trying to protect the
police and they throw paint on her
look the portland mayor isn't mad
because
people might get hurt he was concerned
over the optics
think about that he didn't want b-roll
for donald trump he didn't care about
the people there
he cared that donald trump might win
based on
his abdication his abdication has
created the b-roll
that would take you it would only take
you two minutes to go on twitter
anywhere else
and find a half a dozen videos including
what you just saw
so basically it was his denial of this
that
perpetuated the evil that has created
this mess even
even the new york times is admitting
they were wrong
i wish today was like a we can swear day
because
i really want to swear i mean
that mayor that mayor if you looked up
pile of crap in the dictionary
ted wheeler's face would be right there
because he is legitimately a pile of
crap
for abdicating his moral spine his
leadership which has allowed all of this
to happen i know that i'm just saying
what dana said but louder
and i'm gonna kind of synthetic uh juan
i'm gonna try to synthesize
uh dana's point with greg's point uh
the mayor the mayor inserted
presidential politics and we've heard
democrats refer to law enforcement as
storm troopers and the gestapo
where is the criticism on the left for
shooting lasers and attempting to blind
police officers
for hurting innocent victims including
ones using a walker
why not are we just not hearing it is it
there and the media is not covering it
where is the outrage on the left
i think you just heard it from ted
wheeler i mean you know people here
saying oh
ted wheeler was negligent or something
but i think he's very clear trey in
saying
that what those people were doing was
violent
and it was potentially murderous he used
the word murder that it was wrong so i
think that's pretty clear
why i think people disagree about well
he should have been tougher
earlier and the like but i don't think
there's much disagreement from
left or right when it comes to people
who would set a fire
uh and and trap people in a building i
just think that's illegal it's wrong
it's immoral on so many levels so i just
don't think it's a political divide
there
i do think that he's also right when he
says
that the trump campaign wants those
videos and he's trying to use that to
say to these people who are engaged in
violent behavior
hey are you supporting trump because
trump wants to undermine the power
of the peaceful protest in this country
and the way to do it is to point at
people who are misbehaving and engaged
in illegal activity
so i think he's right on both counts and
i don't think there's a left-right
divide
over condemnation of violent people
well juan i i guess my question is
waiting until attempted murder
is on the table is a long time to wait i
mean you've got to jump over a lot of
other crimes
arson and assault to get to attempted
murder where was the criticism
30 days ago 45 days ago i mean everybody
is against murder for the most part
how about the other stuff leading up to
it
well you know this is about again local
control
and i think that ted wheeler is pretty
popular his citizens saw him as
containing this rather than pouring
accelerant on it which is what we saw
when you had federal agents
from customs out of place showing up for
no reason
and exacerbating a difficult situation
for local officials
kennedy let me ask you this all right no
no no reason no reason i did some quick
research
minneapolis is 1700 miles from the
pacific northwest
what does a state local police officer
committing a crime against an innocent
citizen in minnesota
have to do with what we are seeing in
the pacific northwest for those of us
who like causal connectivity
what is the connection between what
happened to george floyd
and what we're seeing on the west coast
that anarchy
there is no longer action at a distance
here and
whatever movement and whatever momentum
was created
uh in the murder in the wake of the
murder of george floyd
that is completely dissipated in
portland and that's why i called ted
wheeler the nutless wonder i am from
portland it's a beautiful city
it's disgusting what's happening because
ted wheeler is walking around going
hey this is really bad you guys someone
should do something about it's like
ted you're the someone you're the guy
who's supposed to be leading your city
you're the guy who's who's supposed to
be ensuring that there is safety so
people can
protest so when there are a list of
things
that people want changed in their city
with their community policing
you can achieve them you can't when we
have what's going on
and now it is so absurd i think that ted
wheeler is a trump operative
i think he has laid back so long and let
his city burn
because he knows it is a gift to the
trump campaign
that is the only way to explain it and i
feel greg's frustration
and every business owner and every cop
and every person with a family who wants
to live a good life in a beautiful city
and they absolutely cannot because it
has been hijacked and for those of you
who are peaceful protesters and i see a
lot of my friends on facebook and
twitter
posting images from the protests they go
to where they feel like they're
accomplishing something
you better differentiate yourself from
the people who are trying to commit
murder
and if you don't that's on you
well i was listening cl carefully and i
think i heard a mayor's race in your
future
stick around the fastest sevens up there